[Applause]
[Music]
france is probably the only country that
makes the
americans look humble the ego of the
french is so colossal that it doesn't
even fit within its own
country's borders which explains why the
french spent the 19th century
colonizing other countries almost half
of africa was a french colony and a bit
you could probably guess now the most
widely spoken language in sub-saharan
africa yep that would be french
[Music]
but not only that you've probably heard
that latin america is the united states
backyard
right well we could say that africa is
kind of like the backyard of the french
for example
in 2011 france led every military
operation against gaddafi
[Music]
two years later francois hollande's
government sent troops to defend the
president of the central african
republic
while at the same time french soldiers
were also fighting islamic terrorists in
mali
basically the french army has been
present in virtually every
african armed conflict france even
actually controls the currency that many
african countries use
in other words even though african
countries gained independence from
france
decades ago it still maintains a strong
influence on their governments
you can call it soft power you can call
it diplomacy
or you could simply call it colonialism
2.0
and i probably know what many of you are
thinking right now
france has got to be getting rich off
its 2.0
african colonies right well actually
nothing could be further from the truth
here
[Music]
in the last 10 years france's trade with
africa has dropped from 10
to 4.7 percent you heard that right even
though france
dominates african politics its economy
is
an entirely different story in fact
after
centuries of colonialism and
neo-colonialism
african countries have barely evolved
hardly any new companies have emerged
due to french investment
and meanwhile france is spending
billions of euros every year
to maintain its influence over the
continent even though
ultimately it barely gets any benefit at
all
but i bet you can guess who's reaping
all of the benefits
from this collaboration with africa yep
of course we would be talking
about china
chinese companies and africa need each
other like never before
for the last 10 years chinese investment
has changed
the skyline of almost all african cities
some countries like
ethiopia are becoming industrial powers
especially
in the textile sector chinese companies
aren't only taking advantage of the
cheap labor they have also found
a new market to sell their products to
chinese mobiles are
sweeping across africa and more and more
people are learning
chinese in other words while france
sends soldiers
china sends businessmen and it looks
like it's actually working out pretty
well for them
so the question remains why has france
failed to
capitalize on its influence in africa
and what can the new french president
emmanuel macron
do to improve the situation today well
we're going to answer this question but
before we do let's take a look at the
history
the disadvantages of paternalism those
of you who've been
following visualpolitik for a while know
that after world war ii every african
country became
independent from its colonizers
[Music]
but make no mistake not every colonizer
behaved the same way
for example spain had two colonies in
africa sahara and
equatorial guinea so when these two
countries decided to become independent
the spanish government's reaction was
pretty much
wait we have colonies in africa really
and then they pretty much just let them
go because they had enough to worry
about back home
something similar happened with italy
they invaded ethiopia during mussolini's
time
and weren't in a position to resist any
decolonization
[Music]
however france was very different at
that time the french president was
this guy charles de gaulle charles de
gaulle was
how could we define him he was kind of
donald trump but a little bit more
politically smart
france cannot be france without its
greatness charles de gaulle
now on the one hand charles de gaulle
had pretty much no choice but to allow
its african colonies to become
independent
maintaining colonies is really expensive
and france had to focus on rebuilding
itself but as you can imagine
a government with so much ego wasn't
going to give up
its old possessions so france kept its
army in all of its former colonies
and from the elysi palace decided to
support
every one of the political elites that
had begun governing these new
african countries
[Music]
for example in 1964 the french army
supported a coup
in gabon since then the country was
governed by omar bongo's dictatorship
for more than 40 years
and who supplied all the weapons here
well of course it would be france
in return gabon follows french foreign
policy to the
letter and is its main uranium supplier
as you probably know france is one of
the countries with the most
nuclear power plants in the whole world
well the uranium they use
it comes almost entirely from gabon and
of course they get it at a favorable
price
[Music]
gabon without france is like a car
without a driver france without gabon
is like a car with no fuel omar bongo
president of gabon for 42 years and the
same goes for
other countries such as the ivory coast
whose president was also placed by
france in 2011.
the previous president left the palace
under cannon shots
and guess who was pulling the trigger of
those cannons well yes it would be
french soldiers
in return the ivory coast is france's
main coffee
and cocoa supplier french influence in
the region is so complete that even the
currency they use
is controlled by france so-called cfa
franc is the currency being used in 15
of west africa's countries such as mali
burkina faso and
ivory coast
and it turns out that the central bank
that issues this currency is required to
keep at least half of its foreign
currency reserves in the french treasury
and since its creation the cfa franc has
been linked to the french currency
it used to be the french franc and now
it's the euro this means that when the
euro rises or falls
the cfa franc follows
[Music]
but wait a moment because there's some
fine print here and that fine print is
the productive economy
in other words france has been running
its former colonies policies
for decades but these countries have
remained just as poor as when they were
independent
with the exception of the ivory coast
the french-influenced countries in
africa tend to have
underdeveloped agricultural and
virtually stagnant economies
no french company has bothered to open
factories in africa and the money that
came from the elysee was
invested in weapons or extracting
natural resources
after all who wants to do business in
africa well
you probably already know the answer to
that
china we've told you a thousand times
here on visualpolitik
china is africa's main trading partner
since the 90s china grew economically
like there was no tomorrow and when one
starts growing
one needs resources so far nothing new
but unlike france or many other western
power china realized that africa was
more than mines and oil fields i believe
africa is going to become the next
manufacturing floor
for the world and poverty will not be a
destiny
and millions of people in africa will
escape
poverty thank you all
the woman you just heard is helen hai
and she's a chinese businesswoman her
company
is hua jian and it makes shoes for big
brands if you have guests or calvin
klein shoes it's very likely
that they were made by this company and
i bet you can't guess where its biggest
factory is
well it's actually located not in china
but in addis ababa
ethiopia's capital
[Music]
i mean think about it in the 90s china
was the mecca of cheap labor every large
american or european company would set
up its factories and cities such as
shenzhen
or quang seoul but as the country grew
salaries grew too
and by the year 2011 helen high realized
that if she wanted to cut costs in terms
of salaries
she needed to find another country and
that country was ethiopia what's more
helen high wasn't traveling alone she
had the chinese government support
which addressed the ethiopian political
elites and told them look guys
if you just let us do things our way we
can cover the country with factories
with money and jobs and as we often say
at visualpolitik as
it was said so it was done
the hawasa industrial park is already
operational and ethiopia wants it to
become
a manufacturing hub but we're not just
talking about ethiopia here
there are chinese factories in many
other countries twyford is a company
that manufactures ceramic tiles and its
main plant
is on the outskirts of nairobi in kenya
and
we can also find new industrial parks in
other countries like ghana and even
though chinese companies are supported
by the government
we're mostly talking about private
investment here and
i probably can guess what you're
thinking right now that these companies
are making cheap things so they can sell
them to rich countries
right well actually not really for
example startimes is a company in
tanzania made with chinese capital and
it provides cable television since they
reached the market cable tv prices have
dropped by 90
[Music]
thanks to that more than 10 million
africans can enjoy a service that was
once a luxury
and the same is going on with telecom
companies like huawei have flooded the
market with cheap mobile phones in fact
nowadays the same amount of kenyans use
mobile phones as europeans and of course
to connect
all these industrial centers the chinese
government has spared
no expense do you remember the new silk
road we talked about previously the
so-called one belt one road project that
xi jinping launched well the same thing
is happening in africa and we're talking
about
thousands of kilometers of railroads and
roads that have changed
the landscape of several areas of the
continent
[Music]
in other words unlike france china
hasn't tried to colonize africa but
instead has turned them
into business partners and thanks to
that they have managed to earn
more money and more influence
[Music]
the confucius institutes are raising
generations of pro-chinese mandarin
speakers throughout africa
and now you might be wondering well what
could france do about this
are they just going to sit by while
china engulfs the market
well we'll see
[Music]
common interests it probably won't
surprise you to learn that a large
number of african countries aren't
exactly
legal safety paradises that have a lot
of respect for the law
we're often talking about dictatorships
here others are simply failed states
that can barely contain the fights of
various tribes
that means that setting up a factory in
a country like gabon is much more
complicated than setting one up
for example in a place like the united
states
[Applause]
it isn't enough to buy land and get a
permit you need to have government
contracts
that means in these cases diplomacy
plays
a fundamental role remember how i told
you that france controls its former
colonies governments with an iron fist
well you can imagine
the rest of the story here
french companies must go on the
offensive and fight the growing
influence of rival china
for a stake in africa's increasingly
competitive markets
france's minister pierre moscovichi said
on saturday
as you can imagine if france doesn't
want china to invest in its former
colonies
it has enough tools to prevent it and
that's why chinese money has
barely reached these countries of course
beijing has paid for some projects in
countries like the ivory coast and cabin
but that's little in comparison to
ethiopia or kenya
however things could start to change the
new french president emmanuel macron has
promised to turn the african situation
around
and it looks like it's already started
macron revives france's partnership with
china in africa
as macron said at the press conference
china has the money and we
have the knowledge of the region in
other words france would be willing to
allow the african politicians they
control
to accept chinese investments in return
they'd require a piece of the pie
of course this news is from january 2018
so there's still
a lot to do before we can see how this
agreement turns out
so now the question becomes do you think
france will change its policy concerning
africa and start treating its former
colonies as trading partners
or will they just continue to exchange
nice words well leave your answer in the
comments section below meanwhile if you
want to know how africa is leaving
poverty behind please do click
on this other video and don't forget to
visit our friends at reconsidermedia.com
they provided the vocals in this episode
that were not mine and remember that we
publish brand new videos
every week so hit that subscribe button
and you won't miss a single post also if
you like this video give us a thumbs up
and as always
i'll see you next time and if you want
to learn more about politics and hear
even more of my lovely voice
you can join us at reconsider media we
have a podcast at reconsider media.com
podcast see you there